[Musique]
ils étaient 14 collèges en lice pour
cette première édition du concours
signer collège tous avaient réalisé un
court métrage d'une dizaine de minutes
sur le thème une quartier mon collègue
chez moi la cérémonie de projection et
de délibérations du jury s'est tenue au
théâtre de champ fleuri
vous allez de jjg remédier de 20 pc le
départ en premier si parler de
l'inclusion scolaire du harcèlement et
de la découverte de son quartier sous
forme de fiction d'aventuré d'imaginaire
ces collégiens ont travaillé l'écriture
les jeux d'acteurs ainsi que la
réalisation audiovisuelle nazairien la
caméra
réfléchir un scénario monté tout ça
génial vraiment l'initiative est très
belle puisque c'est de faire prendre
conscience en fait que c'est tout un
métier
le collège elie wiesel remporte le
premier prix pour son film le chaudron
et nous en fait l'histoire d'un jeune
qui vient dans le vivier de rentrer dans
le chaudron et à la réunion le chaudron
il est mal vu avec que tout est cassé
donc iran est dit que ben il dit que
c'est des barbares des to et au fur et à
mesure ils vont en fait c'est cool en
fait si prix ont été décernés dont un
prix du jury
une première édition réussie tout juste
terminée et déjà ces collégiens se
prépare à repartir en tournage
[Musique]